Сонячна енергія заворожує. Її видобуток не спричиняє викидів - і вона дійсно дешева.
Але якщо щось звучить надто добре, аби бути правдою… у цьому має бути якийсь підступ, чи не так?
Ви маєте спершу виготовити сонячні батареї - це лишає вуглецевий слід.
Але ще відпрацьовані сонячні панелі важитимуть понад удвічі більше, ніж усі сьогоднішні світові пластикові відходи!
Схоже, сонячна енергія не така вже й зелена, як багато хто з нас може думати.
Та чи справді це так? Ми розглянемо три головні проблеми сонячної енергії.
Крім того, розповімо, чому ви, ймовірно, ходите… у старих сонячних панелях. І до чого тут серіал "Пуститися берега". Поїхали!
Спочатку погляньмо на вплив сонячної енергії на клімат.
Сонячні панелі виробляють електроенергію без викидів. Що звучить вкрай приголомшливо, але це ще не вся історія.
Адже на їхнє виробництво витрачається багато енергії.
Сировину потрібно видобувати, транспортувати, переробляти, а потім - усе це збирати до купи.
І оскільки світова економіка все ще переважно працює на викопному паливі, це означає: викиди парникових газів.
Але питання в тому, скільки? І як багато це в порівнянні з іншими джерелами енергії? Щоб відповісти на це, є така річ, яка називається…
Оцінка життєвого циклу.
Це Гарвін Хіт, який досліджує це багато років. Тож нехай пояснить, як це працює.
У контексті виробництва електроенергії послуга, яка надається, - це генерація кіловат-годин.
Роль оцінки життєвого циклу полягає в тому, щоб зробити якнайповніший облік,
наприклад, викидів парникових газів, які спричиняє виробництво цієї кіловат-години.
Результати такі: в середньому сонячна енергія виділяє близько 40 грамів CO2-еквіваленту на кіловат-годину, яку вона виробляє.
Що насправді дуже мало в порівнянні з викопним паливом - таким як природний газ: 500 грамів СО2-еквіваленту.
Або вугілля - з цілою тисячею!
Але з іншого боку, сонячна енергія виділяє трохи більше CO2, ніж енергія вітру. Який висновок робимо з цього?
Викиди парникових газів між різними відновлюваними джерелами енергії насправді не повинні визначати вибір.
Усі вони забезпечують значну перевагу при заміні традиційних викопних джерел енергії.
Більше того, сонячна енергія стає дедалі більш ефективною, що може ще більше знизити викиди СО2 протягом життєвого циклу.
У майбутньому можуть з'явитися навіть абсолютно нові сонячні технології, наприклад, модулі з перовськіту.
Вони мають використовувати менше енергії у виробництві та перетворювати ще більше сонячного світла в електроенергію.
А потім очікується свого роду ефект снігової кулі.
Що більше буде використовуватися сонячна батарея, то чистішою вона ставатиме, виробляючи ще більше чистої енергії.
Отже, так. Якщо бути точними, сонячна енергія не цілком вільна від викидів.
І все ж, це одне з найбільш екологічно чистих джерел енергії, які має людство.
Для виробництва сонячних елементів потрібно доволі багато хімічних речовин.
Наприклад, у процесі рафінування кремнію утворюється тетрахлорид кремнію.
Його можна переробити, а потім використати повторно.
Але не зовсім зрозуміло, чи завжди виробники роблять це.
Якщо він потрапить у воду, це може мати руйнівні наслідки для довкілля та здоров’я людей.
Або візьміть плавикову кислоту, яка необхідна для очищення сонячних пластин під час виробництва.
Це дуже корозійна кислота, з якою слід поводитися вкрай обережно.
До речі, саме її Волтер та Джессі в "Пуститися берега" застосовують, щоб розчинити останки своїх ворогів.
Ми маємо багато небезпечних хімічних речовин, які використовуються для виготовлення сонячних панелей.
Це Шейла Девіс із Коаліції з боротьби з токсичними речовинами Кремнієвої долини.
Вона розробила рейтинг Solar Scorecard.
Ми не хочемо вирішувати кліматичні проблеми за рахунок інших важливих екологічних проблем,
таких як проблеми з небезпечними відходами, проблеми з ресурсами чи хімічні проблеми, пов'язані з токсинами.
А це неабияк стосується сонячної енергії.
Тобто вона зелена, але вона зелена лише в одній фазі.
Ми ж хочемо переконатися, що вона зелена протягом усього свого життєвого циклу.
Інша проблема полягає в тому, що залежно від типу сонячного елемента та виробника небезпечні матеріали,
такі як свинець, кадмій або миш’як, можуть опинитися в модулях.
Але дедалі частіше з’являються й альтернативи.
Одним із ключових компонентів пошуку безпечніших альтернатив є можливість продемонструвати те,
що називають альтернативною хімічною оцінкою.
І, на щастя, зараз у нас є потенціал для цього.
Можливо, 10 років тому ми не могли.
Але тепер ми маємо штучний інтелект, у нас є машинне навчання, у нас є інтернет речей.
Усі ці комп’ютерні технології дозволяють нам знаходити альтернативи, безпечніші альтернативи, набагато дешевші.
Тож, так. Хімічні речовини, необхідні для виготовлення сонячних елементів, є проблематичними.
Справді потрібен тиск на галузь, щоб вона знаходила альтернативи - і замінила токсичні речовини, як тільки ці альтернативи знайдуть.
І нарешті поглянемо, куди всі ці панелі йдуть "помирати".
Сонячні панелі служать близько 30 років, часто навіть довше.
Нині частка відпрацьованих панелей у глобальному смітті все ще відносно невелика, близько 250 000 метричних тонн.
Але до 2050 року очікується, що ця частка зросте до 78 мільйонів метричних тонн.
Це ніби понад 200 хмарочосів Емпайр-Стейт-Білдінг, викладених зі старих сонячних панелей.
Уже тепер ми бачимо, що це буде проблемою, яка, звичайно, у найближчі 10-15 років перетвориться на велику кризу.
Старі панелі нагромадять гори електронних відходів, з якими людству просто так не впоратися.
Добра новина полягає в тому, що сонячні панелі підлягають переробці. І це вже робиться, переважно в ЄС.
Тут уряди зобов’язали виробників переконатися, що їхні відпрацьовані панелі переробляються.
Такі об'єкти, як оцей, вже переробляють значну частину матеріалів. Але є й погані новини.
Наприклад, перероблений кремній ще не має високої чистоти,
а це означає, що ми не можемо використовувати його для створення нових сонячних панелей.
Замість цього він іде на виробництво інших речей - наприклад, підошв для взуття. І тоді виникає інша проблема.
Витрати на переробку є відносно високими, і це частково тому, що поки що не так багато можливостей для переробки.
Це означає, що в тих місцях, де немає законодавства, яке зобов'язує переробляти старі сонячні панелі,
наприклад у США чи Китаї, все одно дешевше викидати їх на сміттєзвалища.
Переробка має стати прибутковою - інакше у нас може виникнути справжня проблема.
Було би багато, багато, багато сонячних панелей, які вивозять на звалище. Таке годі собі уявити!
Юн Луо - генеральна директорка ROSI Solar, французького стартапу, який розробив новий процес переробки.
Він зосереджений на відновленні найцінніших матеріалів високої чистоти.
Насправді економічна віддача скла не така висока.
Тому ми намагаємося також інтегрувати в цей процес, яка цінність буде в переробленої сировини.
Кремній і срібло разом - це лише близько 3 відсотків загальної ваги.
При цьому в ньому 70, навіть більше 70 відсотків економічної вартості.
За допомогою такого підходу ці матеріали можна було б переробляти з прибутком, аби потім повернутися до виробництва сонячних панелей.
Зараз фірма готується до відкриття першого заводу наприкінці 2022 року.
У принципі, якщо ми дійсно зможемо створити економіку замкненого циклу, нам не треба буде переробляти всю цю сировину.
Тож добра новина полягає в тому, що сонячні батареї МОЖНА переробляти.
Погана новина полягає в тому, що багато з них - ще не переробляються.
То що все це означає? Гаразд, сонячна енергетика не зовсім зелена.
Але це точно не означає, що ми повинні відвернутися від неї. Її переваги надто великі.
Замість цього ми повинні відверто розглянути її проблеми і - з’ясувати, як ми можемо їх виправити.
Тепер ми хотіли би почути вашу думку з цього приводу.
Як ми маємо боротися з не дуже зеленими сторонами зелених технологій?
Дайте нам знати про це у своїх коментарях.
І якщо вам сподобалося це відео, будь ласка, тисніть на підписку.